[MUSIC PLAYING]
STACEY KULONGOWSKI:
So I'm thrilled
to be here with you personally.
I'm a mom of three girls,
as I told you earlier.
I literally jumped at the
chance to preread this book
and to take the journey
on motherhood with you.
I absolutely loved,
loved, loved the book,
as I've told you
many times on email.
But I absolutely love the book.
And we have books for you
all here in Ann Arbor.
So I invite you to take
them with you when you go.
You'll absolutely love it all.
Just to set a little
context for the book,
it's a short story collection.
There's 12 stories of
all different women
with all different points of
view of becoming a mother,
or an early motherhood
experience, I would call it.
So it's absolutely
a great journey.
I loved how candid you were.
I felt like you told so many
behind-the-scenes stories.
I think as mothers, a lot
of times we get so afraid.
And there's a lot
of shame involved
in sharing some of
these stories of seasons
that are really hard.
So as a result, we
don't share them.
And then when our fellow mothers
walk through these seasons,
they feel so isolated
and alone that they're
the only ones going through it.
So I felt that you
empowered me as a reader
and as mothers everywhere
to celebrate these truths
and share these truths.
So I just wanted to thank
you for that to start with.
I thought that was beautiful.
I thought your writing was
very raw in some places
and very romantic,
which I loved.
And I think the
most impressive--
because I read a ton.
One of the most
impressive things
that you do in these collections
is character development
in such a short amount of time.
It's really unbelievable
how you do that.
Polly takes us into the
middle of someone's story
and drops us as a reader
right in the middle.
And yet you're so connected
to these characters.
And you want them to win.
And you want them to triumph.
And you're in the
season with them.
And you really want the
stories to end well.
So I thought that that
was really remarkable.
So a bit more on Polly
before we get too into it.
Polly has published stories
in an extensive amount
of well-read publications
and magazines.
She's a book reviewer.
And many of her
reviews and her essays
have been published in "The
New York Times Book Review,"
as well as many
other publications.
She's a teacher as well,
teacher of creative writing,
from all levels from elementary
to college students as well.
And now she is a
freelance writer
and a fiction editor for the
"Michigan Quarterly Review."
So she's a local
here in Ann Arbor.
And she lives with her
husband Cody Walker,
who is a poet and teaches
at U of M as well--
so I don't know if anyone
knows Cody Walker--
and their two daughters as well.
So pleased to have you.
So before we begin our
chat, I heard a rumor
that you're going to read an
excerpt of the book for us.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yeah.
Well, first I want
to say thank you,
Stacey, so much for all of
that and for reading the book.
And thanks to you
guys for coming out.
I love that people are eating
their lunch while you're
listening to me talk
about mothers and babies
and that kind of stuff.
I really appreciate
your being here.
So those of you
who have children
may be familiar with
the fact that it
can be really hard to get
children to go to sleep.
And I wrote the story that I'm
going to read some of to you
today out of that frustration
of having a new baby
and trying to get the
baby to sleep in her crib,
which seems like such a simple
thing, but actually was not.
So this is the last
story in the book.
It's called "Parental Fade."
And I'll read about the
first third of the story.
"Parental Fade."
You can do it the
long and painful way
or the quick and painful
way, the pediatrician says.
The quick and painful
way, otherwise known
as "crying it out," means
putting the baby in her crib
at bedtime, shutting the door,
leaving her there till morning.
Whatever it takes to
ignore the cries--
blast the TV, have noisy sex,
take turns leaving the house--
this is what we must do.
The long and painful way is
called a "parental fade."
Put the baby in her
crib and get comfortable
in the rocking chair.
Don't pick the baby up.
Try not to even touch her.
Wait for her to settle
her own self down.
Cry herself to sleep.
Each night, move the rocker
farther away from the crib.
Remain in the room for a
shorter amount of time.
Crying it out takes
a few nights at most.
Parental fade may
take several weeks.
Either way works.
It's up to you, the
pediatrician says.
He is the gentlest, smilingest
man we have ever met.
He sings our baby's name when
we bring her into his office.
He keeps a musical
frog on the ceiling,
sets it swinging as he draws
the needle for her shots.
Look at the frog,
he croons happily.
We cringe.
We fear the baby will
develop a phobia of frogs.
We are exhausted, despairing,
mad at each other and at all
parenting manuals,
at all parents
whose babies don't
regard their cribs
as horrible cages of doom.
Our insurance covers a
30-minute sleep consultation.
It's coded as a necessary
medical intervention.
Now our 30 minutes are up.
The pediatrician offers a
final compassionate smile.
Believe me, it works.
You'll be surprised.
You'll be relieved.
You'll be OK.
In the car on the way home,
we consider our options.
Can we get a hotel
room for the weekend?
Pay the babysitter to do this
cry it out all night thing?
Can we commit to two
weeks of being stationed
in a rocking chair, pretending
to ignore our screaming child?
Can we accept that
a baby crying is
nothing more than a baby
crying, that this is
only the first of many battles?
And we must be strong.
We must not yield.
We must stay fixed on the
goal for the good of all.
Our daughter in her
rear-facing car seat
gnaws on the legs
of a rubber giraffe.
She is 10 months old, crawling,
pulling herself up to stand,
pointing, clapping, shaking her
head no, saying "da" and "ma,"
not necessarily in
reference to us.
She has two teeth on top and
one about to break through
on the bottom.
She eats mashed sweet
potato and peas and banana
but not spinach or
apricots or squash.
She has her father's
broad forehead
and rounded nose, her
mother's hazel eyes
and loosely curling brown hair.
She will fall asleep in the
stroller and the car seat,
in our bed and in our arms.
When she's asleep
in our bed, she
sprawls out, hits and kicks us,
sends one of us to the couch.
The other one sleeps
fitfully, afraid she
might suffocate or roll
off of the unattended side.
If we sneak her into the
crib, she usually wakes up.
If the sneaking
thing actually works,
we tiptoe around and
speak in hushed voices.
Perversely, we miss her.
We are in our 40s.
We look it and feel it.
This doesn't fit with our vision
of how the world should work.
We should be 23 always,
uncertain of the future yet
convinced of the
promise it holds.
Though we could potentially be
the parents of a 23-year-old,
we feel too young
for parenthood.
"Mama" and "dada"?
How can these words apply to us?
We still have trouble
with "ma'am" and "sir."
No, we have to remind ourselves.
This is how the world works.
Our own parents and stepparents
are senior citizens,
retired, ailing, acquiring
new knees and hips,
losing their memories.
All of our
grandparents are gone.
Pictures of these people from
another time line our mantle.
They are young there, dashing
in their military uniforms,
zaftig in their
bathing costumes,
stern in their wedding attire.
We would liked to
have known them then.
But we were born too late.
The '70s will be as
remote to our daughter
as the '30s are to us.
So it's decided.
Starting tonight, parental fade.
An aging rock band, a
haircut for the going bald,
a chronic illness,
the way of the world.
We wish we could do
quick and painful,
but let's be realistic.
As soon as we put
the baby in her crib,
she'll stand up and scream.
She'll either never
lie back down,
or she'll collapse
in a mangled heap.
She'll cry so hard
she'll throw up and then
choke on her own vomit.
We'll have to go in and check
on her, and all will be lost.
Actually, we believe the
pediatrician is right.
The baby would be fine.
She'd work it out on her own.
In the morning when we entered
her bedroom, guilt ridden
and spent, our daughter
would smile her smile
of delight, her oldest and best
trick, the smile she offers
to anyone who shows
her a bit of interest,
but most of all to her parents,
who are most in need of it.
She's a narcissistic insomniac,
preventing others from sleeping
if she cannot.
A sentimental whore, refusing
to sleep alone in her own bed.
The most grating
of alarm clocks--
no radio option,
no snooze button.
But here are her trump cards.
She smiles as if she
herself had discovered joy.
And she never holds a grudge.
We just can't do
quick and painful.
Though we're not those kinds
of parents, the ones who
declare on their blogs that
letting your baby cry herself
to sleep leaves
psychological scars,
gives the kid lifelong feelings
of security and abandonment,
our objection is not on
philosophical grounds,
nor is it out of genuine fear
for the baby's well-being.
We believe fundamentally--
we have to believe--
that the baby will
always be all right.
No, we're softies,
weaklings, cowards.
It's easier for us to
do things the hard way.
I'm going to stop there.
And I'll keep you in
suspense as to whether
these desperate parents ever--
STACEY KULONGOWSKI:
Figure it out or not.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Get this
parental fade thing going,
yeah.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: So good.
I think so many of us as parents
can really-- and side note,
I was like, can you pay
the babysitter to do this?
Is this actually a thing?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE:
I didn't try it.
But I want to know, too.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: Let me know.
Let's talk.
Awesome.
So thank you so much
for sharing that.
I loved that
chapter in the book.
So just to jump into
some of the questions,
there's so many motherhood
books out there, as you know,
about the blessings and the
challenges of motherhood.
And your approach was
so interesting to me
because it was all about
this season of prebirth
to very new newborns.
How did you choose that that
was the piece of journey
that you wanted to
tell the stories about?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yeah.
Well, just to tell you a little
bit about my own background,
I have two daughters.
They're eight and five now.
So pretty much for
the past decade,
I have been in the season of
thinking about having a baby,
getting pregnant, having
a few miscarriages, which
is something I address in the
book, and then having a baby
and thinking, wow, I
have a baby all the time.
How am I going to handle this?
And so it's a period that's
very much been on my mind
and in my life.
And I don't know
if anybody knows.
In Ann Arbor, there's
an organization
called the Center for
the Childbearing Year,
where you can take birthing
classes and breastfeeding
classes and learn how to
take care of your newborn.
And so I kind of
thought of this book
as the book of the childbearing
years for these various women.
And so just to give
you a little sense
of the kind of
chronology of the book,
it's all different characters.
But it starts with a
couple who are having
a hard time conceiving,
want to have a baby
but are struggling with it.
There is a story about a woman
who is not ready to be a mother
and has an abortion.
There's a story about a
woman who has a miscarriage.
There's stories about other
experiences of pregnancy.
There isn't a story
actually about childbirth
because I found that
I could not actually
write about that experience.
It was a little too physical.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI:
Still too soon.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yes.
I didn't feel I was fully
there when I was giving birth,
though I certainly was.
So then there's a story about
postpartum depression, which
I struggled with, a
story about introducing
the new baby to extended
family, going all the way up
to that story that
I read part of.
Baby is 10 months.
You've almost made it
through the first year.
And you're having
these challenges
in getting the baby to sleep.
So I really wanted to
limit it to that time frame
and to zoom in on what's really
special and really amazing
about that time
frame, but also what's
really challenging in it.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: I love that.
How did you know that we
needed to hear these stories?
And how did you know
that you were the person
to bring them to us?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yeah.
Well, when I was experiencing
this time myself,
I had only been living in
Ann Arbor for about a year.
We had moved for Cody,
my husband's, job.
And so I didn't know
many people here.
I knew a few other people
that had young children.
But I spent a lot of time
on the phone with my friends
who had had babies and wheeling
the baby in our stroller
through the neighborhood
and talking to people.
But I also spent a lot of
time alone with the baby.
And I found that
really difficult.
And I kept a lot to myself.
And then when my
partner would come home,
I would burst into tears.
Some of it would come
out anyway at that point.
So I think the thing
about having a new baby is
that it's so wonderful.
And everyone congratulates you.
And it's like your
family is complete.
And this thing that
you've wanted to happen
has finally happened.
And so you kind feel like,
well, I can't really complain.
I shouldn't be having
these negative feelings
about this thing that
I've wanted and now have.
And it's a blessing,
and it's beautiful.
So I really felt like when I
talked with other people that
were experiencing
some of these things
that it was really
helpful for me.
And I wanted to put
that out there myself.
And for me, writing fiction
has always been a way.
Even though I fictionalize
the characters
and I fictionalize
the situations,
it's always been a way for me
to address complicated emotions
that I have myself.
And so I didn't write
actually until my daughter
was about a year and a half.
And then I found that I
could get back into fiction
and look back on
these experiences.
And then I knew I was
thinking about having
another child, which scared me.
But it was also like, OK, I
kind of forget this stuff.
And I need to know
it for the book.
OK.
It'll be research.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--and have another baby.
And then I didn't
write right after she
was born either for a while.
But fiction has always
been a way for me
to tap into my own
emotions and explore
the inner lives of people.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: Love that.
Love that.
How did you choose--
or why did you choose, rather--
to tell multiple stories
versus create one large novel?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Right.
Well, so I started--
I had always wanted to be
one of those people that just
wanted to be a writer
since I was five years old
and knew what
being a writer was.
But I didn't really seriously
start writing fiction
until I was in my mid-20s.
And I started off
writing stories.
The short form really
appealed to me.
And I was kind of afraid of
writing a longer work, a novel.
But I went to graduate
school for creative writing.
An MFA degree is what
I got, a Master's
of Fine Arts in creative
writing and fiction.
So I was in my early
30s at that point.
And I entered into the
program thinking, OK,
now I'm going to get serious.
I'm going to try
to write a novel.
Those of you who
read fiction probably
lean towards novels and
not story collections.
So I thought, OK, I'm
going to attempt this.
And in the first semester of
the program, I started a novel.
And then you all here at Google
will shake your head at me,
but my computer died.
And I did not have a
good backup system.
And I lost the
beginning of my novel.
But the thing was,
I didn't care.
It was kind of
like, good riddance.
That wasn't working.
And so at that point, I
really kind of embraced it.
You know, I want to keep
writing short stories.
I love this short form where
you jump in for a little while
with the character.
And then you jump back out.
And you can move on
to something else.
So I really dug into
the short story form
and kept going with it.
And the characters, as I said--
in some story collections
that are linked,
you might have
different characters
appear across the stories so
it feels a little bit more
like a novel.
But for me, I just
wanted to keep
entering into these
different women's experiences
and to capture a range of
people and a range of things
that they were going through.
And so this format really
worked for me in that way.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: That's
so interesting, too,
because my next question
absolutely related to this
is around parallels.
Because I think that
was the piece that
wove them all together for me.
I was actually writing
them down at some point,
like, oh, she's
associating this with this.
And it was so interesting to
see how you wove these themes
and variations between all
of these different characters
throughout even one
story or many stories.
So I thought that that
kept the reader feeling
like they were belonging
in the same type
of a holistic book of work.
So for me, even in the
story "Tanglewood,"
Sam instructs Elise.
He says, listen for themes
and variations of symphonies.
And I was like, wow, this is
an absolute beautiful parallel
to your work, too.
I thought that
was so interesting
how you wove that in there.
So how did you think
about the interweaving
of themes and variations
across either one
story or all stories?
What was your goal around
that when you wrote this?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yeah.
Well, a lot of story
collections don't
have an overarching theme.
And they're just
sort of stories.
And there are many
story collections
that I love that are like that.
But for me, when I was
writing stories and thinking
about putting a book together,
I felt a little bit lost.
So when I hit upon
this idea one day
while I was paying
for child care,
my daughter was a
year and a half.
And I was over at
the Malletts Library.
And I thought, why
don't I do this?
Why don't I create
this chronology
of stories that are
all thematically linked
through having a baby, but
each one is their own thing?
And so of course, the
overall theme of the book
is motherhood and
becoming a mother.
But there are a lot
of other things, too.
There are a lot of romantic
relationships in the book.
There's one character who gets
pregnant from a one-night stand
with a guy from France.
And he's off.
And she's never going
to see him again.
And he's never going to
know that he's the father.
So they're very brief
romantic episodes.
But then there are also
long-term, committed
relationships where people
are having a baby together.
And how does that affect
their relationship
for the woman to be pregnant
and then to have a baby?
So I was really interested
in exploring that.
I also was interested
in exploring
familial relationships
between mothers and daughters,
between sisters, between
extended families.
And also friendships among
women is another theme
of the book-- and
relationships that women
have with each other,
which in some cases
can be really supportive.
But then there are
also certain jealousies
that come up when someone
is trying to get pregnant
and someone close to
her gets pregnant.
And so I wanted to think about
those relationships as well.
So I think they're all
connected with the idea
of being intimate
with other people
and figuring out who
you are as you enter
into this period of
becoming a mother
and what kinds of conflicts come
up that impede that intimacy.
But yeah, something different
happens in each story.
And they're all about
different characters.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: So good.
So good.
How did you choose
the title of the book?
So I know it comes up in one
of the first stories, maybe
the first story or the second.
How did you choose
that that was what you
were going to name the book?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Well,
the title was hard.
Titling is hard for me.
Sometimes when I set
out to write a story,
I know what it will be called.
But most of the time I don't.
And I write the whole story.
And then I think,
what in the world
am I going to call this thing?
And a lot of story collections--
you use a title of
one of the stories
to then title the collection.
But looking over my
titles, I just thought,
there's nothing that really
captures the book as a whole.
So for a while--
and I'll watch your expressions
when I tell you this.
For a while my possible
title was "Baby Person."
OK.
A few of you maybe like it.
[LAUGHTER]
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: Market
research right here at Google.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yeah.
But I told a few
people the title.
And they kind of gave
me this blank look.
What do you mean "baby person"?
Like a person who's
kind of like a baby?
And what I meant
was that expression,
like you're a baby person.
You love babies.
You think they're
cute and adorable.
Or you're not a
baby person, which
is what one of the characters
in here says at one point.
I'm not really a baby
person, actually.
And that's true for me.
I love kids.
But babies aren't
necessarily my thing.
Then I had two of them.
I also had a friend--
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: They
become kids, though.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Yes.
Mine are now eight and five.
So I survived.
But yeah, I had
one friend tell me
that "Baby Person"
made her think
of a man who had like really
tiny, little hands, kind
of like "Boss Baby."
And this was just all
not what I was going for.
And then just to tell you
a little bit about how
books become books
if you don't know--
so I had this manuscript.
And I looked for
a literary agent.
And agents will
help you try to sell
your collection or your fiction,
your nonfiction, whatever
it is to publishers.
And so I had this agent who
had agreed to work with me.
But she said, we're
not sending this out
to publishers with this
title, "Baby Person."
That's just not going to fly.
So I had to come up
with another title.
And as you mentioned, Stacey,
the title appears in the book.
And so I kept combing
through the book.
There has to be something in
here that I can call this.
So I'll just read you the
little section where it appears.
And it's the first story.
And in this story, the
narrator and her husband
are trying to get pregnant.
And it's not working.
And the narrator's
sister, Audrey,
has thought that she
would never have children.
She wasn't interested
in having children.
But she becomes pregnant.
But in the scene that I'm going
to read, it's before that.
And she's at a Thanksgiving
gathering with her mother.
We don't feel the
need for children,
Audrey told our mother
last Thanksgiving.
You have to need them, I think,
so much that you don't think
you can be happy without them.
Mom shook her head, proud
and sad on its wrinkled neck.
That's not how it works.
You can't know the joy until.
She swiped at a tear
that was about to fall
into the wild rice stuffing.
You just can't know it.
Look how happy I'm
making you, Audrey said.
So it comes up in
the book in that way.
And when I hit upon it,
I really liked that--
what does it suggest?
Of course kids do make us happy.
And they're such
a source of joy.
But at the same time,
I think if we're
being really honest
about it, there
are a lot of times that
they don't make us happy.
And they drive us crazy,
both little kids and adults
with their relationships
with their parents.
So I liked that the
title was ironic.
And then it sort of
got at this complexity
of what the experience
of becoming a mother is.
Yes, I finally got it.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI:
That's so good.
All right.
Next we need your advice, OK?
So one of the tough challenges
that we have here as mothers--
all Googlers probably, but
mothers here at Google--
is finding the time and
energy to do it all.
It can sometimes feel
like at work in home
that it's always ever
going-- and in a good way,
too, sometimes, and in a
good way very challenging.
And I don't love the
notion of balance.
I don't think that's a word that
we should all be striving for.
I think it's a difficult
one to achieve.
It doesn't set us
up for success.
But I love this
notion of energy,
how we create our energy.
So I would love your advice
to all of us here at Google.
How do you optimize
your energy level
for motherhood and writing?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Wow.
Well, my house is a mess
because the domestic scene--
I just kind of let a
lot of that stuff go.
And I'm pawing through my
laundry baskets that are
in my bedroom every morning.
I'm like, I never have time
to put these clothes away.
So I think I've really chosen
to make work a priority.
And it's been different
for me because I've always
juggled part-time jobs.
And I work from home.
And I do freelance.
And the writing I
pretty much never got
paid for until I finally got
paid something for this book.
So I often also feel like
I have to kind of justify
working and make the space
to work because I could be--
I'm home.
I could be taking
care of the kids.
And I could be doing the
dishes and all of that stuff.
So I feel like I've really
had to decide for myself.
I love working.
And I have to prioritize
and let other things go.
And I honestly think, too, that
quality time over the quantity
of time is really important.
So my kids have been going
to full-time childcare
since they were quite young.
Sometimes we pay for
babysitters on the weekends.
And I'm off to the
library getting work done.
But then when I am
with them, I feel
like I enjoy them so much
more than if I were trying
to juggle everything together.
And I also think that it's
important for my kids--
my daughters
especially-- to know
that my work is important
to me and that I value it
and that I love it and
that I've chosen work
that I really care about.
And I think it makes me a better
mother to be able to just stake
out that work prioritizing
along with the kids.
But I loved this conversation.
And I'd love to hear
from you guys how
you guys manage it all, too.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: Any tips
from the audience afterwards?
Catch Polly afterwards, too.
Yeah, I see some
nodding of heads.
Great.
So I think we'll do
one more question.
And then we'll move
on to Q&A here locally
but will end the video portion.
So if you left us readers and
mothers with one key takeaway
from the book, or if
there's anything else
that you want to say to this
community, what would that be?
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: I
think the key takeaway
for me is that becoming a
mother, becoming a parent--
it's such a rich and
fascinating experience.
And once you are one, you're
always going to be one.
You're a mother all the time.
But I think there are
so many challenges
involved in it as well.
And I think that being
honest with ourselves,
open and honest with other
people, with other women--
I mean, as you said
at the beginning--
so that women who
feel kind of alone
in their difficult experiences
don't feel so alone.
And I think it's
also important for--
especially our male partners--
to realize, especially
in that period of being pregnant
and giving birth and going
through so much hormonal
and physical stuff,
that this is difficult.
And I also think it's
important, again,
for our kids to know that
we are their mothers.
But we are also full
people in the world.
I know I always felt
that about my own mother.
STACEY KULONGOWSKI: Well,
thank you so much, Polly.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you all for joining
us at Talks at Google.
And we so appreciate it.
And good luck on your tour now
that the book launches today.
So thank you so much
for being with us.
POLLY ROSENWAIKE: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]